heute also bund länder treffen heute
geht es zur sache aber in welchem tempo
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit bild live
chef claus strunz bei uns im studio
schönen guten morgen claus guth
das ist das tempo das ist das tempo
nicht dass
ich was ist das tempo der
werden von heute die beieinander sitzen
denn anders kann man das ja nicht nicht
bedachten als in einer ironischen
ernährung alle fakten liegen auf dem
tisch die jetzt gelten und man könnte
heute sagen jetzt freiheit und man
könnte sogar sagen wir meinen wirklich
freiheit denn was mit diesen drei stufen
plan da diesem
dramatischen sich der freiheit annähern
tatsächlich gemeint ist ist ja nicht
freiheit sondern es bleibt ja die masken
pflicht in innenräumen sind pflicht dann
wenn sie nicht freiheit und es soll ja
auch wenn mich nicht alles täuscht immer
noch dieser verwegen idiotische gedanke
eine allgemeine impfpflicht im parlament
beschlossen werden das ist doch auch das
wort pflicht also auch das gegenteil von
freiheit wir haben mehr noch heute geht
es auch darum müssen sich den pfleger
und menschen in krankenhäusern entlassen
per pflicht so umstritten also der große
die große liebe zur freiheit ist noch
nicht ausgebrochen bei unseren jungen
der ist wenn ich umgelegt und ich kann
einfach nicht nachvollziehen warum ich
war ja von anfang an der auffassung dass
die massnahmen verhältnismässig waren
das ist nie angemessen war was man den
menschen aufgetragen dann aber ich
konnte immer noch nachvollziehen so ein
bisschen mit welcher logik man es
gemacht hat also selbst als größter
kritiker der maßnahmen musste man sagen
also wenn die krankenhäuser wie ist da
nichts voll laufen was auch schon eine
wirklich gelungene formulierung ist wenn
immer mehr menschen die um ihr leben
kämpfen da sind wenn das passiert dann
tue ich mir schwer jetzt dazu twittern
alles muss weg alles idioten die das
fordert aber jetzt ist es doch so dass
die faktenlage sich gedreht hat und mein
wunsch wäre einfach immer eine hoffnung
wäre einfach das mit der gleichen
entschiedenheit wie wir uns in lockdown
und freiheitsbeschränkung und
freiheitsentzug begeben mussten
jetzt davon befreit werden und das ist
nicht zu erkennen welche rolle spielt
der gesundheitsminister spielt karl
lauterbach was müsste er machen und auf
welchem kurs ist er ganz offen karl
lauterbach ist ja vielleicht das größte
phänomen der deutschen politik der
jetztzeit ja also weil es ist ja noch
immer nicht entschieden ob er ein
geschick dampfplauderer talkshow hält
ist der mit halbwissen und einem studien
fetisch sozusagen mehrheiten erreicht
oder ob er ein medizinexperte ist der
sich seriös im namen der bürger für
deren wohl einsetzt das ist
unentschieden und ich finde in diesen
stunden fällt die entscheidung wenn er
jetzt weiter seine angstmacher politik
verfolgt wenn er jetzt weiter sagt wir
können noch nicht lockern weil sonst
fällt vielleicht irgendwo noch mein
vogel vom himmel wegen cola oder sowas
ja wenn er das jetzt weitermacht dann
ist er das erste dann finde ich fehlt
ihm die eignung zu einem bundesminister
der einfach größer denken muss der auch
die positiven aspekte sehen muss der die
freiheit höher bewerten muss als die
einschränkung und das liegt heute
sozusagen auch mit auf den tisch das ist
heute auch ein schicksalstag für lautern
ich will noch ein foto zeigen klaus uns
beschäftigt ja immer die frage durch die
zunehmenden proteste auf der strasse
gegen die korona maßnahmen kann man
jetzt demonstrieren auf der straße
natürlich kann man das aber mitnehmen
marschiert man da im zweifel mit was
sind jetzt nazis was es jenseits des
grundgesetzes was nicht eigentlich ganz
leicht zu erkennen bei vielen zumindest
schau dir dieses bild hier an da ist es
zumindest einfach klaus also bis jetzt
habt ihr schafe gejagt wie es sind wolf
oder wölfe heißt es wahrscheinlich da
muss man nicht mehr lang nachdenken und
da bin ich auch in meiner bewertung
komplett ein eindeutig wer hinter einem
solchen plakat herläuft ist vielleicht
selber noch kein nazi muss sich aber
schon der kritik ausgesetzt sehen dass
er mit nazis gemeinsame sache macht und
gemeinsam auf die straße geht warum weil
formulierungen die auf schaf und wolf
abzielen sind eindeutig nazi sprecher
derjenige der das sozusagen in die
rhetorik eingebracht hat joseph goebbels
und den gibt's ein sehr berühmtes zitat
und jeder der das verwendet absichtlich
dann ist es dann ist es nazi wenn man es
ab ich verwende diesen hat sie also wenn
die das plakat gemacht haben absichtlich
das so formuliert haben sind sie nazis
da gibt es dann auch keine ausrede mehr
wenn sie dumm sind und hinter solchen
plakat verlaufen ohne den bezug zu
kennen dann muss bildung her und dann
müssen sie wenn sie es jetzt hören dass
sie hinter diesem plakat her gelaufen
sind hinter diesem banner müssen sie von
sich selbst angeekelt sagen das machen
wir nicht mehr ich will nämlich einmal
das zitat kurz vor lesen damit klar wird
dass das jetzt nicht irgendwie nur so
eine kurzfristige erregung ist das zitat
auf dass das zurückgeht stammt von
joseph goebbels propaganda minister von
adolf hitler aus einer zeitung die der
angriff ist nazi zeitung und dort hieß
es wörtlich wir kommen nicht als freunde
auch nicht als neutrale wir kommen als
feinde wie der wolf in die schafsherde
einbricht so kommen wir das ist der
nukleus dieser verkommenen
spalterischen rassistisch aufgeladenen
rhetorik und wäre damit heute auf die
straße geht der macht sich schuldig
danke bild live chef claus strunz ihr im
studio